ALL RIGHT, I’M COMING DOWN.
WHEN I CAN TRAVEL, I’M COMING
DOWN.
THANKS SO MUCH.
WE WILL CHECK BACK WITH YOU IN A
COUPLE WEEKS.
AS SOME BUSINESSES DO REOPEN, MY
NEXT GUEST IS CAUTIONING THAT
MAY WILL BE A TRANSMISSION TRANS
HERE NOW IS LARRY KUDLOW.
YOU HEARD THAT BARBERSHOP OWNER,
HE SEEMS LIKE A REALLY COOL GUY,
WE CAN GET BACK TO WORK SAFELY,
A FREE MARKET BELIEVE HER, AND
YOU LOVE THAT STORY IS MUCH AS I
DO.
GO AHEAD.
>> ACTUALLY COME I GOT TO TELL
YOU, I’D LOVE THAT GUY AND I’M
ALSO GOING TO CONFESS, I HAD A
HAIR TRIM YESTERDAY.
IT WAS KIND OF A SPECIAL DEAL.
FRIENDS -- YOU KNOW THIS PERSON,
NOT MENTIONING ANY NAMES.
SHE GOT HER HAIRDRESSER TO COME
IN AND OPEN UP HER BARBERSHOP
AND THE GUY GAVE ME A PRETTY
GOOD TRIM.
I DON’T HAVE MUCH TO WORK WITH
BUT IT LOOKS MUCH BETTER BECAUSE
I WANT IT TO LOOK GOOD ON THE
LAURA INGRAHAM SHOW.
THAT WAS THE KEY POINT AND HERE
I AM.
I HAD NO TEMPERATURE THIS
MORNING COMING INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE, I TESTED NEGATIVE
LAST WEEK, I FEEL FINE, AND I
LOVE THAT GUY.
I’D LIKE TO MEET HIM SOMETIME.
>> Laura: LARRY, SO YOU’RE
SPECIAL.
YOU GOT A HAIRCUT.
THE REST OF US, WE ARE DEALING
WITH IT.
NOW, I’M JUST KIDDING.
BUT MAY IS A TRANSITION MONTH.
GOT TO GET THIS ECONOMY GOING.
PEOPLE ARE DYING OUT THERE.
AT THAT GUY, THAT WAS SAD, THE
OPENING TO THAT STORY.
I’M BLEEDING MONEY, I’M GOING TO
GET MY CAR REPOSSESSED.
THAT IS THE AMERICAN
UNDERSTANDING RIGHT NOW IF WE
DON’T GET THIS THING GOING.
THINK BRIAN KEMP IS GOING TO END
UP BEING A BIG SUCCESS STORY.
>> I TOTALLY AGREE.
I MEET THE GUIDELINES AND WE’VE
GOT GOOD, SCIENTIFIC-BASED
GUIDELINES.
YOU’VE GOT TO HAVE YOUR
ADJUSTMENT IN SPECIAL CASES
WITHIN A 14-DAY PERIOD.
HE FED TO OBSERVE IT.
HE RAN IT DOWN PRETTY WELL.
YOU’VE GOT TO HAVE THE TESTING,
THE CLEANING, THE HAND WASHING
AND ALL THE REST OF IT.
AND THE DISTANCING.
BUT IF THAT IS TRUE, IF YOU MEET
THE CRITERIA, I THINK YOU’RE
GOING TO SEE A LOT OF STATES
OPENING IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
AND I THINK THE MONTH OF MAY
IT’S GOING TO BE A TRANSIT TERRI
TRANSITION MONTH AS THE ECONOMY
REAWAKENS.
IT WILL BE ROLLING, PHASE AND AT
TIMES.
26 MILLION PEOPLE, LAURA.
26 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE LAST
FIVE WEEKS HAVE FILED
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS.
60% OF THE WHOLE WORKFORCE.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE THAT.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE -- IF WE ARE
FORTUNATE, THEN YOU KNOW WHAT,
THE NUMBERS WILL KEEP COMING
DOWN AND PEOPLE WILL REOPEN AND
WE LOOK AT THIS ECONOMY
RESTARTED AGAIN.
>> Laura: THE WHITE HOUSE IS
CONSIDERING TONIGHT, APPARENTLY,
WE LEARNED OF A LIABILITY SHIELD
THAT WOULD PROTECT EMPLOYERS
FROM LAWSUITS RELATED TO
CORONAVIRUS.
BUSINESSES SAY THEY NEED TO
REOPEN OTHERWISE THEY’RE GOING
TO GET SLAMMED WITH LAWSUITS.
CRITICS SAY IT’S JUST GOING TO
EXCUSE THAT OF CONDITIONS,
UNSAFE ENVIRONMENTS.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> THAT’S JUST NOT TRUE.
I MEAN, LOOK, COVID-19
GUIDELINES.
YOU’VE GOT FEDERAL GUIDELINES,
STATE GUIDELINES, CITY, COUNTY
GUIDELINES.
THAT IS WHAT THE STORES AND
SMALL BUSINESSES, THEY HAVE TO
ABIDE BY THAT.
IF THEY DO, THEN I THINK THERE
SHOULD BE A SAFEGUARD AROUND THE
LIABILITIES RELATED TO THE
COVID-19 VIRUS.
THERE SHOULD BE A SAFEGUARD.
LOVE, IF YOU GO TO A RESTAURANT,
JUST TAKE THIS EXAMPLE.
YOU GO TO A RESTAURANT THAT HAS
RECENTLY OPENED.
THE RESTAURANT OBSERVES ALL THE
GUIDELINES, OKAY?
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM.
NOW UNFORTUNATELY, IF THE
CUSTOMER COMES DOWN WITH THE
VIRUS, UNFORTUNATELY, HOW CAN
YOU PROVE NECESSARILY THAT IT’S
THE RESTAURANT’S FAULT?
BECAUSE THIS THING IS HIGHLY
INFECTIOUS, AS YOU KNOW.
I DON’T THINK WE SHOULD OPEN THE
DOOR TO A LOT OF FALSE CLAIMS BY
TRIAL LAWYERS AND OTHERS WHO ARE
ALWAYS ON THE LOOKOUT.
HE WILL STOP THE BUSINESS FROM
OPENING OR THE BUSINESS WILL
CLOSE OR THEY WON’T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO KEEP GOING BECAUSE OF
THESE LAWSUITS, SO WHY NOT HAVE
SOME SAFEGUARDS?
AND BY THE WAY, I THINK BUSINESS
BUT ALSO THE EMPLOYEES IN THE
BUSINESS SHOULD BE PROTECTED
FROM THESE KINDS OF PHONY
LAWSUITS.
>> Laura: I THINK THERE IS
INCREDIBLE WISDOM IN IT.
I THINK IT HAS TO HAPPEN.
THE ECONOMY HAS TO GET GOING, WE
HAVE TO GET BACK TO WORK.
DO IT SAFELY BUT LET THE FREE